يحاول الزعيم الفلسطيني الصائب محمود
عباس الآن توضيح
التعليقات التي أدلى بها والتي تقارن
معاملة إسرائيل للفلسطينيين
بالهولوكوست 50 محرقة ، يقول إن هذه
التعليقات تم إجراؤها في ألمانيا مباشرة
أمام هاداس الذهب للمستشار
في القدس يضايق ما فعله
عباس  قل وماذا كان رد الفعل
جيدًا كريستين ، هذه ليست
المرة الأولى التي أدلى فيها محمود عباس بتعليقات
مثيرة للجدل أو كتب فيها تعليقات مثيرة للجدل
حول الهولوكوست في الماضي
قال أشياء مثل يهود أوروبا
جلبوا محرقة الاضطهاد على
أنفسهم.
من المسلم به على نطاق واسع أن 6
ملايين يهودي لقوا حتفهم ولكني أعتقد أن
هذا واحد جديد يدلي بهذه التعليقات
حول الهولوكوست في ألمانيا بالطبع
حساسة للغاية بشأن دورها في
الهولوكوست حول علاقتها الآن
مع إسرائيل ، وما حدث
كان في الأساس  مؤتمر صحفي
يقف إلى جانب المستشار
الألماني وسئل عما إذا كان  كان
يعتذر لإسرائيل وألمانيا
بشأن مذبحة ميونيخ الأولمبية
حيث قُتل 11 رياضيًا إسرائيليًا
وضابط شرطة من ألمانيا الغربية على
يد إرهابيين فلسطينيين
وأجاب بالعربية قال إذا كنت تريد
الذهاب إلى الماضي قال إن لدي 50
ارتكب مذبحة إسرائيل 50
محرقة وقال كلمة محرقة
باللغة الإنجليزية ، وهكذا
فهم الجميع الآن ،
لم يتفاعل المستشار الألماني شولتز على الفور بينما
كان على خشبة المسرح بجوار رئيسه ، لكنني
أريد أن أكتب تغريدة أرسلها
بعد بضع ساعات قائلًا إنني أشعر بالاشمئزاز
من التصريحات الفاضحة التي أدلى بها
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس بالنسبة
لنا نحن الألمان على وجه الخصوص ، أي أن
نسبية تفرد
المحرقة أمر غير مقبول وغير
مقبول.
تلقى التعليقات
إدانة واسعة النطاق هنا في
إسرائيل ، حيث غرد رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي يار لبيد
أيضًا على تويتر قائلاً:
كانت تعليقاته وصمة أخلاقية وكذبة شنيعة
أن ستة ملايين يهودي قتلوا
في المحرقة بما في ذلك
مليون ونصف المليون طفل يهودي والتاريخ
لن يغفر أبدًا.